[Music]
Becca's hoping that she can pull off
finding love on The Bachelorette yep her
journey to be the Bachelorette began on
May the 28th and we were exclusively
invited to Becca's Bachelorette photo
shoot how will you handle a villain on
your season what we do I'm trying to
weed out all of the dramas I don't want
drama if there's a guy that's not
meshing well with the other guys
probably let's do the damn thing
Becca is clearly ready to move on after
Ari and only we can show you her new
Bachelorette promo filled with plenty of
attitude we have the show is almost near
the end of production and when your
Becca has made some real love
connections she's falling I think she
definitely sympathizes with Arie now I
don't know if she's gonna go down the
same road as Arie but I think she
understands now how that can happen it's
a good group it's a good group of dudes
I'm and I am harsh I'm a harsh critic of
the guys just because I can be yeah and
I'm very protective of my bachelorettes
this is a good group they are definitely
worthy and I think fingers crossed so
hopefully she's gonna find love biggest
fear going into this my biggest fear is
I mean kind of what happened like
falling for somebody and ready to spend
my life with somebody and have them not
be ready or to be like I don't know if
you're the one for me
only eg on lines lauren zima was with
becca as she shot her first photos as
the Bachelorette and she told us she'll
be handling things very differently from
her ex I think I'm very blunt and very
honest and I think I'm just a little
more peppy I know at the end of the day
I will make that right choice because
I'm not going to take this situation
lightly I'm not going to let everything
else get to me when it's that big of a
decision for my life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]